le succès et l'échec voyage toujours
ensemble ils sont les hôtes permanent de
l'homme le premier est parfois beaucoup
plus humble et discret au point de ne
pas montrer sa présence au début alors
qu'il est le plus nanti des deux vous
fait le bonheur de l'homme
mesdames et messieurs c'est citation
provient de mon ouvrage un livre dans la
voiture et si j'ai l'affectionnent
particulièrement et que je la partage
c'est parce que cette citation est un
condensé des valeurs qui sont les
miennes et qui sont la persévérance
l'endurance et la résilience
je suis demandé mais la main et je vais
vous raconter mon parcours par coup qui
m'a amené de la gare routière à
l'université
[Applaudissements]
c'était un jeune homme de 22 ans qui
attendait beaucoup de la vie et que la
vie n'a pas déçu c'est une image qui a
une préhistoire
quelques années plus tôt en classe de
sixième j'avais perdu mon frère aîné qui
est en classe de seconde et donc j'étais
déjà fils aîné et quelques années plus
tard je me suis fait renvoyé de l'école
en classe de troisième au mauvais
résultats et plus tard je me suis
retrouvé chez mon oncle à gagnoa où j'ai
passé une année scolaire sans aller à
l'école ensuite j'ai obtenu le pc au
cours du soir
ennaji du boeuf pc je suis venu à la
capitale à abidjan avec la ferme
résolution de passer le concours
administratifs et finalement ce fut
véritablement une succession d'échecs
après ses échecs aux différents concours
administratifs
je suis encore est venu à gagnoa où je
me suis retrouvée à la gare et je
conduis cette peugeot 404 pendant deux
années dans le transport en commun
je faisais le tronçon gagnoa oumé
toumodi dimbokro yamoussoukro bouaké et
après ces deux années passées dans le
transport en commun
je suis encore est venu à abidjan pour
passer deux concours administratifs et
finalement au lieu d'un qu'aucun niveau
bepc
j'ai réussi un concours de nouveau ses
épées et je suis devenu chauffeur de
l'administration je sais que dans la
salle il ya beaucoup de personnalités
qui sont venus avec les chauffeurs et
qui attend le décor dans la voiture je
ne sais pas si quelqu'un vous déjà
quinze jours son fils devienne
chauffeur sais pas s'il ya une main à
part à moi je n'en vois pas pour ma part
moi j'étais très heureux de quitter la
gare c'était déjà l'avènement des cas et
il n'y avait pas assez de passagers et
de quelques passagers que j'arrivais à
trouver réfusé d'ailleurs de monter dans
ma vieille voiture de peur de ne pas
pouvoir arriver à destination
pour ma part je t'aime
j'étais également heureux de quitter la
gare en fait j'allais devenir
fonctionnaire
j'attendais toujours les ja répéter ce
mot fonctionner un mot que je
l'appréhendé pas du tout à l'époque
fonctionner j'entends les gens dire il
n'y a pas de petits un fonctionnaire est
tout simplement un fonctionnaire et donc
j'allais quitter la guerre pour mapa
j'allais devenir chauffeur et donc on me
met à la disposition du ministère de la
production animale main j'étais
les chauffeurs mais mes rêves n'était
pas pour autant briser et quand je me
rendais chez mon patron à domicile à la
maison son cadre de vie ne faisait
d'ailleurs que booster mes rêves aiguisé
mes ambitions
oui je vous le dis pas je remarque que
la qualité des mets sur la table à
manger je voyais comment les enfants ont
été éduqués et je voyais comment ceux ci
pouvaient souffrir de loisy à coups de
billets à coups de billets de banque
et chaque fois que j'accompagnais les
enfants à l'école
je me posais la question de savoir
quelle serait ma vie si j'avais connu le
même sort que ces enfants là et quand
j'accompagne le grand le plus grand à
l'université j'avais quelques fois un
sentiment de remords je me disais que
c'est tellement je n'avais pas fait
assez d'efforts au collège
et voilà que cela me rattraper et moi je
voulais tout fait vous quittez la
pyramide
vous quittez la base de la pyramide de
maslow je faisais un travail des
chauffeurs à un saint un travail de
nouveaux cpu petit diplôme petit salaire
et je me posais beaucoup de questions et
je vais demander ce que j'allais fait et
je viens d'amis
jamais un ami que j'avais déjà rencontre
que vous allez plutôt un compagnon
fidèle
ou peut-être que vous imaginez pas mais
le livre le livre qui est elle devenue
mon compagnon fidèle et je vois que mon
patron c'est ouvert les gnons je me
mettais à lire et scellait puis assidus
vous avez réussi à forger un mois une
personnalité un auto les gares et
c'était la lecture se transformer en de
véritables conversations en des échanges
avec de grands auteurs de grands
penseurs qui semblait me dis tous les
matins mais la matu n'est pas différent
des autres
tous les hommes ont les mêmes
potentialités qu'elles chauffent eu mes
consoeurs min soo platon tous les hommes
ont les mêmes potentialités mais la
matière réussie avec un des fois soutenu
et je n'ai pas été indifférent à ce
message
et parfois je me demandais comment est
ce que j'ai fait vous mêler vie et un
jour
plongé dans mes pensées j'attendais mon
patron dans la voiture quand il a monté
à l'arrière du véhicule
je voulais mettre le moteur en marche et
mon patron m'a demandé d'attendre que
l'internât collaborateurs et sur le coup
je regarde dans le rétroviseur de la
voiture et je vois mon patron en train
de réajuster sa coiffe et je me pose la
question quelle est la différence entre
le patron et moi selon vous quelle était
la différence entre le patron en bois et
une voix intérieure m'a répondu à 10 ans
l'une des différences en patron et toi
c'est l'instruction c'est la formation
et la dû faire des choix et 7ème mois de
sa vie tu dois te prêter a fait des
efforts je suis allé m'inscrire au coût
de soir suite à la rencontre d'un procès
deux français qui avaient été épaté par
ma capacité de rétention et j'ai obtenu
le bac à l'âge de 40 ans
aussi
bah si c'était un chauffeur bacheliers
et après le bac c'est un ami m'a tendu
au débattement de l'efs modèle ou en
droit à l'université
moi je suis allé m'inscrire au
département d'anglais parce que je
voulais devenir bilingues dans un pays
francophone
sans oublier le fait que j'étais parfois
quel gouffre quelquefois frustré de ne
pas pouvoir lire c'est un beau livre en
anglais mais il y avait une autre une
autre raison oui il était déjà
intéressant il faut le dire de voir un
chauffeur ces instruments en anglais
alors que certains patrons pas plus
complexe le faisait pas ouvrez la bouche
et dans la journée je m'acquitter de ma
tâche des chauffeurs au ministère et le
soir j'étais étudiant à l'université
trois ans plus tard j'ai obtenu une
licence en anglais
[Applaudissements]
oui une licence en anglais en
littérature et civilisation américaine
j'ai également obtenu un diplôme
d'administration et mona du mal dans une
grande école et en tant que grand
lecteur j'avais aussi un autre rêve
celui d'entrer un jour dans le royaume
des immortels en tant qu'écrivain
[Applaudissements]
et le vrac c'est une grande satisfaction
morale se livrent un train de changer
d'avis surtout au niveau de la jeune
génération
et depuis trois ans l'ouvragé au
programme au collège jean piaget
l'établissement d'application de l'école
normale supérieure d'abidjan ouvrage oui
la prime a franchi la black tu m'as
anobli ouvrage m'a valu le troisième
prix d'excellence en littérature le
produit le plus de sens du présent la
république en 2016 et mon prix
littéraire porte la signature de son
excellence dahlia 42 ans vice président
de quoi tu vois quand il n'était plus
ministre et
[Applaudissements]
merci et si cela plus le chauffeur
s'était caché il voit rien et si c'est à
l'aéroport de dubaï en partance pour la
république populaire de chine
c'est un séminaire regroupant 40
africain les 14 pays francophones dont
quatre ivoiriens
je suis reconnaissant à mon patron qui
m'a recommandé et au cours de la
cérémonie de clôture
il se trouvait que j'étais le seul
écrivain parmi les 40 participants et
géo fait deux exemples l ouvrage au
visuel de la situe à l'endroit des
étudiants à présent le français l'échec
dans la vie sept cantons l'abandonnent
je pense que docteur kahlaoui l'a dit
tout
tout se passe dans l'esprit no limits
parfois c'est dans notre esprit l'homme
ne connaît vraiment les chèques dans la
vie que quand il abandonne
beaucoup de personnes n'entreprennent
pas par la peur de l'échec
le manque d'estimé soit le manque de
confiance en soi
il arrive à certains de se rabaisser
eux-mêmes et de surdimensionner le
mérite d autres oubliant que nous tous
nous avons des fausses nous avons
détecté des talents qui sont cachés et
dont nous ignorons quelquefois
l'existence ici
ça au mali à ségou aux bords du djoliba
comme sésame qui ont été éprouvés par
l'érosion
l'érosion à balai le sable magasins
résistent comme cesab l'être humain cela
parfois éprouvé par le coût de la vie
c'est à l'homme d'avoir cette endurance
et défier la vie chacun de vos le
devront oser nous devrons rêver oui
répond il faut rêver il faut savoir
rêver
et quand nous l'avons enlevé le pont new
rave d'action pour réussir en d'apps il
ne faut pas l'enveloppé des craintes et
d'hésitations le docteur l'avait dit la
peur j'ai accompli
c'est un rêve dans ma vie pendant les
années chaque fois que j'arrivais à
l'université je rêvais quand
j'accompagne est souvent le patron
pendant plus de vingt ans à l'aéroport
et je rêvais je me disais maintien je
veux voyager un jour en tant que cadres
ivoiriens au delà côte d'ivoire et je
voudrais que vous aussi parce que vous
êtes porteur des talents du faux sang
vous chacun de vous vous portez de
potentialités et je voudrais alors que
vous aussi vous vous armer de courage de
volonté d'espoir deux fois dieu m'a
permis de réaliser cette inde où mes
rêves vous aussi je ne doute pas que
vous pourrez que vous pouvez et vous
devez réaliser certains de vos grands
rêves
[Musique]
m